i start with beth rigby of skye thank
you um
liz trust you've just said that the
country wants a modern and united
conservative party but the two
candidates ahead of you
in this race have one thing in common
they're a break from boris johnson
rishi sonak resigned from his government
you did not and penny morden was never
in his cabinet or only for a brief
moment
and they've leaped frog u in the race
given the bitter divisions of recent
months is boris johnson's tax tacit
backing of you the kiss of death for
your candidacy given that the party
wants change even if you did not thank
you
the change we need to deliver is change
on the economy
we've had sluggish growth for two
decades and we need a new economic plan
and i'm somebody who can work with the
team from right across the conservative
party to deliver
on transforming our economy
cutting taxes for ordinary people across
the country
getting investment into all areas from
the north to the south scotland northern
ireland and wales
helping us
deliver the next general election
but most importantly helping us to live
a brighter brighter future for britain
when so many colleagues did
i'm a loyal person i'm loyal to boris
johnson i supported
our prime minister's aspirations and i
want to deliver the promise of the 2019
manifesto and what we need to do now is
deliver deliver deliver and i am the
person in this race with the record of
delivery i've taken the tough decisions
at the foreign office at the trade
department i've got a fantastic team of
people in my campaign team and more
broadly across the party and i want to
go in from day one in downing street and
make sure we deliver on the promises we
set out in 2019.
[Applause]